is the United States still the land of
opportunity honestly not anymore because
the American dream relies on the one
thing this country is killing the middle
class being middle class today means you
earn between 40 and 120 $2,000 a year
depending on where you live you're not
poor but nor are you rich you're getting
by
back in the 1960s over half of American
households were middle-class but that
middle class has been shrinking ever
since today the median income is less
than it was in 1989 but the cost of
living of course keeps going up in just
the last 15 years the cost of housing
healthcare child care and college have
all skyrocketed that means people are
working longer hours for Less pay just
to keep the lights on how has it gotten
to this
let's start with unions those
organizations that workers belong to so
they don't get screwed by management the
United States has historically had some
of the strongest unions but in the last
thirty years membership has nosedive
back in the 1950s more than a third of
private sector workers belonged to a
union today that number stands at seven
percent check out the share of income
the middle-class takes home compared to
union membership weaker unions weaker
middle class without bargaining power
it's no wonder that the federal minimum
wage has also fallen so what happened a
defining moment was in 1981 when 13,000
air traffic controllers went on strike
President Ronald Reagan responded by
firing them all of them this action put
the US government squarely on the side
of management embolden execs to go after
unions since then there have been waves
of laws passed by states that weaken
union membership which corporations take
advantage of by relocating to states
that have weaker unions and fewer labor
laws that's if they stay in the country
at all
[Music]
why are there fewer and fewer
good-paying jobs we're often told the
technology has a lot to do with it and
yes since the 1970s millions of
manufacturing jobs have been lost to
automation but that's just part of the
story you know those boring trade
agreements that get negotiated in secret
well pay attention because while they're
touted is being great for growth
they've also hurt American workers the
u.s. lost nearly 700,000 jobs mostly in
manufacturing thanks to NAFTA and while
China is a favorite scapegoat it's the
United States that open the doors to
trade without properly protecting its
industry or workers in five years 1.8
million jobs were lost as companies
moved abroad or decided to import you
for goods who knew the American dream
included lobbyists today the biggest
corporations have armies of lobbyists
who make sure that things go the way of
big business in Washington and they
spend 2.6 billion dollars a year to do
just that
that's 34 times the amount that unions
and public interest groups spend and
it's totally legal so is keeping your
profits offshore in order to avoid
paying American taxes that's what most
fortune 500 companies do about those
taxes in 40 years
the top point one percent actually saw
their taxes cut in half whereas the
middle class is paying more many
conservatives argue that rising tides
lifts all boats
but if the rich make more money
eventually it'll benefit the rest of us
but has that actually happened yes the
economy is doing better since the Great
Recession but overall the rich are
getting richer while the majority of
Americans keep getting poor
you
[Music]